welcome to the first annual media
phibi's
a year-end review including awards for
the dumbest the worst the cringiest and
the wokest moments from mainstream media
in 2021.
this video is sponsored by getupside
alrighty we begin today with category
one who is the dumbest cuomo i'm gonna
say it's android
what an honor and pleasant surprise
during these hard times the reason i'm
gonna say it's andrew is because a year
and a half ago andrew cuomo was going to
be president of the united states and
now andrew cuomo is going to be
president of his cell block maybe
next category most spin
this year's winner
nbc's kelly stavis
the reporter who was hearing people
shout as loud as they could joe biden
and somehow turned that into
let's go brandon oh my god such an
unbelievable
moment you can hear the chance from
the crowd
let's go brandon
this has been renamed this year in honor
of the winner the let's go brandon award
very impressive stuff the late night
loser award for cringiest late night
host oh man this is a hot competition
this one wow this category it is stacked
this year so you got jimmy fallon trying
to laugh through the pain with joe biden
i mean i got vacs i got boosted i got
whatever you want i if you want me to
wear red pants i wear red pants
got stephen colbert who's just turned
his show into the democratic socialist
of america roast every evening
[Music]
samantha b i think counts in this
category she's still considered a
late-night host even though no one has
ever seen her show ever there's a severe
lack of awareness trevor noah i believe
is in this category hold on hold on hold
on jewish space lasers
jimmy kimmel how could i forget jimmy
kimmel the woke pope of late night tv
and that's a damn thing
i do have to give it to colbert
which is a real upset in this category
jimmy kimmel is nominated in this
category every single year
the biggest l which journalist or
company posted their biggest l online
nicole hannah jones posted on twitter
this year that the united states had
bombed japan during world war ii with
the
a-bomb because we wanted to prove to the
rest of the world that we had wisely
spent our money on the manhattan project
that is legitimately the stupidest
historical argument anyone has ever made
that the united states basically dropped
the bomb on nagasaki and hiroshima
because of the sunk cost fallacy we're
like oh we got this bomb lying around i
just got to do something with it just
nuke 50 000 japanese people for no
reason next award
the furthest reach
i'm gonna go with the attempt to turn
the kyle rittenhouse trial into a story
about racism
not guilty
it really reveals like how broken um the
system is and i do feel like we're in
more danger today than we were yesterday
that was a big reach pal rittenhouse be
white all the people he shot be white
most nationally damaging fake news story
now for four years running it was the
russian gate story for sure
but
this year i'm going to say that it is
the media's fake panic over covet
these case numbers have been a pretty
good gps of where we are heading when
they go up like this we are heading into
horrible territory their their media
coverage does not strike by age it it
does not pay attention to death rates
now the media's coverage of omicron oh
mercran is the worst media coverage of a
scientific issue i can imagine they
they're literally headlines every day
about how dangerous omicron is meanwhile
the data show that to date one person
one
has been documentedly killed by omicron
in the uk which means o.j simpson has
killed more people than omicron
we have immunocompromised people who are
incubators for every variant to come
walking around lawfully unvaccinated
that's psychotic
it's got to be the media coverage of of
of kovid just generally it's it's it's
not just the most nationally damaging
story of the year it is the most
nationally damaging story of my lifetime
and it's not close
next category the 2021 lifetime
achievement in hackery award
wow
another competitive category i'm gonna
go with someone who's young a little
young for a lifetime achievement award
but has really demonstrated true
hackery above anyone else on tv at this
point and that of course is brian
stelter over at cnn
was the peaceful transfer of power the
name of his show is reliable sources his
entire show is supposed to be devoted to
honest media coverage all he does is
just demonstrate that he is going to
mimic democratic talking points and
cover up bad stuff happening in his own
network while simultaneously whining
about fox there's a new book coming out
about this on tuesday it's called the
brainwashing of my dad he he's done just
an astonishing job so really hats off to
him standing ovation for brian stelter
and honorable mention there to brian
williams who is retiring and in honor of
his prior performance we will be giving
him a non-existent helicopter
next category most overpriced tv host
george stephanopoulos gets paid like 15
million dollars a year
which is incredible for a man who has
never demonstrated ability to do things
i'm george stephanopoulos who who
imagined when when they were inhabiting
the headquarters of keebler as a keebler
elf that he would be making that kind of
money landslide it's it's an incredible
incredible achievement now folks if you
think george stephanopoulos is too
expensive wait until you see how much
you paid for gas this month which means
that you need to lower that gas bill the
best way to do that you need to check
out get upside my listeners are making
up to 25 cents for every gallon of gas
every time they fill up you just
download that free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now use
promo code shapiro get a bonus 25 cents
per gallon on your first fill up that's
up to 50 cents cash back don't pay full
price of the pump anymore get cash back
using it get upside some people who
drive a lot they're making as much as
two or three hundred bucks a month in
cash back there's no catch the cash back
is added directly to your account you
can cash out any time to your bank
account paypal or an egift card for
amazon and other brands just download
that free get upside app use promo code
shapiro get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your first tank of gas that
is promo code shapiro to get up to 50
cents per gallon cash back on your very
first tank of gas george stephanopoulos
may not need get upside but the rest of
us probably do go check out that free
get upside app right now use promo code
shapiro get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your very first tank and up
to 25 cents per gallon after that
worst co-opted influencer
tick tock star benny drama
that intern at the white house routine
wow we have some video of that hey potus
that is horrifying you know that is bad
when you become a me and jen don't
forget to have fun
most hysterical okay so here we don't
mean the funniest we mean like the
craziest out of control
everything is going to end we're all
going to die end of the world joy read
by consensus wins most hysterical hosts
this year i'm so sad that you did that
so sad that you did that oh my god the
dying and darkness award for most
degraded journalism brand okay so i'm
gonna say
cnn
really
the reason i'm gonna say cnn is because
i don't think cnn really does a lot of
original reporting anymore they really
made their bones on live news coverage
and original reporting something is
happening outside
and now they're basically just msnbc
it's all commentary masquerading as
objective journalism the new york times
is a crappy newspaper but they do have
good reporters that are sometimes
working for them and they do spend an
awful lot of money breaking an awful lot
of news they bury all the news in
paragraph 12 of the story and so you
actually have to go in and read the
story to actually uncover what the
headline should be but
i don't think they've degraded their
brand in quite the same way that cnn is
i think you'd be hard-pressed to find
people who think that cnn is honest
journalism these days or as i think you
can still find people who think that the
new york times does some decent
reporting
the starving polar bear award for
achievement in climate reporting i'm
gonna give this to the new york times
the new york times did a a compendium
and it was the world is burning here are
all the areas of the world that are
burning we're all going to die there was
a guy ice skating on a on a
canal in amsterdam and then he sort of
fell through the ice and frankly i
thought that was kind of funny yeah like
i'm sorry but the new york times telling
me how difficult things are how bad it's
gonna be when i am sure that all of the
wealthy patrons of the new york times
have palm beach homes directly on the
beach uh uh so they're not that worried
about global global warming apparently
uh yeah i'm gonna go with the new york
times on this
guys this camera's beeping so you might
want to fix that
it really is the oscars we've just
gone on so long that and judy dench was
20 when we began this
alrighty now we get to the big
categories because we're reaching the
end of this show worst host
wow
so much competition in this category we
had to expand the category used to be
five now it's 10. there's only one host
i think who's really fit for this
category as it turns out worst host just
bad at being a host
unwatchable samantha b
there's no redeeming quality to samantha
b
people are hungry for kind heartfelt
comedy that soothes the heart and spirit
well that's not me fart knockers you
could say that that joy reid you know i
assume if you're on her side of the
aisle you find her kind of wild crazy
brand entertaining in some sort of way
why not the same media attention when
people of color go missing well the
answer actually has a name missing white
woman syndrome and if you are like a
real devotee of cnn maybe you find don
lemons lecturing you about race to be
edifying in some way samantha bee
is a horrifically untalented white lady
who hasn't said a funny thing in years
and whose brand of humor is to
apparently just say
things from the emily's list website
and then
force at gunpoint her audience to laugh
that's why i'm bringing you our new
segment your pants america she's an
actual terrorist
worst show
okay i'm gonna say
because it's true
saturday night live
saturday night live has become
absolutely unwatchable
[Music]
it's like your college roommates at the
local juco who get high
and only read the headlines from yahoo
news and so they're just going to make
insular references to one another in the
most obvious and ridiculous way like
saturday night live has destroyed itself
that if only for that one segment of the
lady dressed up as a clown
[Applause]
ranting about how it's important that
clowns get abortion oh gotcha gotcha i
had an abortion the day before my 23rd
birthday
okay
saturday night live goes to the top of
this list for me
most likely to cry on air ah for the
next year
all of them
because election night 2022 is going to
be a bloodbath for democrats it's going
to be the end of reservoir dogs it's
going to be the shining when the
elevator doors open it's just going to
be it's going to be blood everywhere
we're going to have such a hate watch
festival on election night 2022 it's
going to be spectacular we're just going
to be flipping from msnbc to siena it's
going to be the end of raiders of the
lost ark it's going to be faces melting
and heads exploding and
it's gonna be fantastic there you have
it gang the very best of the absolute
worst in our media institutions comment
below to let us know your favorite award
let us know about any awards that we
missed
[Music]